[Music]
you know I haven't done for a while just
it's the good old fashioned vlog very
early start this morning put up the four
five because I also look at some lasers
[Music]
okay so I've made it to the campus but a
problem which I hadn't anticipated is a
is pretty so huge that I deal with the
code you complain to see this place from
specs so I made it I'm here at the
central laser facility looking at lasers
at the moment and here in the visitor
center so this is the bit that looks
sciency to non-scientists
but earlier we were looking at the
gemini laser and now what i've just been
given is kind of an overview of
everything they do here which is a
mind-boggling array of science from the
very very tiny you know looking at
molecular interactions using Raman
spectroscopy to modeling the very very
big like shine jupiter-like planets like
I said I already had to look at Gemini
and we're about to have a look at it's
sort of the older version of it which is
a more powerful laser called Vulcan so
at some point in the past a beam has
come out of here it's gone through some
optics but it's missed one because
instead of ending up down that end of
the room it burned a hole in the wall
and there's something a bit a clamp a
lamp in from spirit which somewhere has
got a hell of a scorch mark on one side
kind of unusually for science video I've
come here they basically invited me to
do some recording about the lasers here
in the research but we didn't have a
particular video in mind really had a
couple of ideas and since coming here
there's been a particular technique
which I want to make the video file
which is about how they amplify the
signal I'm making this up as we go take
a look at this cable management right so
far so good
alright things are getting a little bit
messy oh my god how on earth to debug a
bit
it's been really fun being here the
laser facility actually like making
stuff up on the fly in terms of
filmmaking is always like a massive
challenge I think it's funny enough a
lot what doing the vlog is like I love
blogging I really do and is what this
channel has become
sort of built on its what made it the
size of careers but problem is I haven't
been vlogging because I just don't
people are life's very interesting
anymore I mean yeah I'm vlogging today
because there was something interesting
happening I went to a laser research
facility and there's some interesting
things happening in the next couple of
days so I thought why not however in
general I have something of a problem
with vlogs at the moment which is that I
think they do better on YouTube when
content which is actually meaningful
that's not to say that I think vlogs
don't have any value I definitely think
there's value to be taken from the
entertainment of a blog but to use all
the power of the internet just to see
what someone's day is like no matter how
interesting that day was when you could
be using it to learn about revolutionary
science or cutting analysis of politics
or deep analysis of history isn't that
just a little bit depressing but then
again not really surprising a phrase
that I really like using in talks that I
give is that YouTube is the world's
campfire people come to the campfire to
hear stories told by individuals and
yeah there are fantastic and very
deservedly popular channels that aren't
fronted by individuals notably Kurt's
curse act real engineering and sideways
come to mind but generally people
gravitate towards channels which are
fronted by personable individuals if you
ask someone what they watch on YouTube
they'll generally give you a list of
people's names not a list of company
names though there are some exceptions
and those are companies which tend to be
fronted by very personable individuals
and why is this well because as humans
we are social animals we are innately
tuned to look for other people's
experiences for other people's emotions
and so when we sit down at the campfire
we look for those narrators who are
personable who we just are drawn to
Casey Liza
zoella so how could we is YouTube then
to communicate stuff about physics
politics or history or non personable
nonfiction if you like because I think
the way that we're doing it at the
moment is kind of pointless in some ways
oh boy thing come with me today I'm in
Camden speak at an event called London
small youtubers where apparently are now
qualified enough to talk about YouTube
and like tell other people what to do
straight to him some will give you about
so I'm here in this quaint rickety but
very cool somebody said old building I'm
doing roundtable about educational
content and then I've got another thing
later which is a panel discussion called
oh that's very niche oh death very niche
so the panel this morning was a success
it was I was talking about educational
content more broadly on YouTube and you
know how we could do it most effectively
I've now been taken out to Camden Market
for lunch which I'd never been to before
but Peter here who I've worked with
before was Matthew Santoro video it
wasn't it which it could they'll be a
link down there don't watch that you
used to live here and then you are
recommending some places to go eat we
are we're gonna go eat some mac and
cheese from the markets it's gonna be
amazing
gonna eat all the carbs oh yeah we need
to go to the gym
[Music]
solid recommendation very very good mac
and cheese
[Music]
well this is all rather lovely we should
probably go back to the conference
though right what was I saying again so
there's this idea called science capital
in science capital is a measure of how
informed and how educated and how aware
you are of the world and how it works
and people me who have degrees I've got
quite high sights capital I've got two
degrees in science I know I'm interested
in how the world works you compare that
to someone who's maybe 12 or 13 who is
in school who maybe doesn't watch
documentaries that do any reading
they're just interested in watching you
know trouble of beauty vlogs or whether
they have low science caps and you can
argue though the whole point of doing
educational content on any platform like
YouTube is to increase science capital
right you want to take somebody who
before the video had a certain level of
science capital and you want to raise it
you want to make them more aware of the
world you want to make them more
interested better educated about a
particular topic but here's the thing
there's some diminishing returns right
as someone's got higher science capital
the return that you get as an educator
on increasing it is increasingly small
right if some I was to watch a video
about how particular thing in the world
works it's gonna raise my science
capital but it's gonna be a smaller
fractional change it's gonna be a less
of a good done than if somebody who had
a much lower science capital it was very
12 years old came away from a video
understanding something much better why
am I talking about this or I'm bringing
this up because most creators on YouTube
and other platforms I should say who
make educational content our aim for
people who have high science capital in
the first place the kind of people who
search for videos like this tank
defeated the Nazis in World War two
they're already interested in
engineering you're gonna be increasing
the science capital sure but it's gonna
be a smaller fractional good than if you
targeted people who were less educated
to begin with as an educator on YouTube
my objective is to good I want to try
and raise people science capital but the
frustrating thing is I'm only reaching
people who can receive the least
fractional difference from it and this
brings me back to vlogs
[Applause]
because here's the thing about vlogs
vlogs appeal to people across the
spectrum people who to quote somebody
who wrote this in a comment come on
YouTube they don't want to think here's
the thing I've been thinking about the
reason I wanted to make this video what
if we would use the vlog in the flog
format as a way of educating as a way of
communicating non-personal nonfiction
because vlogs are done or at least been
perceived to be that perceived to be
this format where you see the thumbnail
you see the kind of title do you think
great a video I don't have to think what
I'm watching it
except blocks don't have to be done as a
matter of fact I received a package
yesterday which kind of illustrates the
fact that you can make vlogs which
educational and also had them be you
know watched by people because since
2012 this channel we're making video
blogs which had a purpose they had the
purpose of trying to educate people
about first Oxford and then secondly
about doing a PhD and then what I was
doing my PhD on and enough people will
subscribe to the channel and believed in
those vlogs being entertaining that well
I just got my silver play button for a
hundred thousand subscribers I believe
that the video blog is a perfect format
to reaching a wide audience and
educating people on the sly in a way I
think my video blogs have shown that you
can make a product which is broad and
perceived as dumb because it's a video
blog but then kind of under the radar
get information across to the viewer and
I think you could argue that using the
format in this way has a greater impact
raises the site's capital of more people
and has a greater positive impact on
those people than a science video that's
particularly targeted to people already
with high science capital something that
I'm going to try and do on this channel
in the future is in a way go back to my
roots go back to the thing which got me
this award but in a different way
because before the point of the vlogs
was very specific it was dictated by my
circumstances I was at university I was
doing research now I think that I'm of a
size what I can and of a technical level
where I can make video blogs which are
going to be educational but sneer
King that education in amongst a dumb
framework something that hopefully I've
achieved in this video already because I
think educating people on YouTube is
important and I think that educational
videos should be more than just lists of
facts it should change the way that you
think and I think the best way to do
that with a wide audience is to
contextualize the educational content in
someone's life my mine I guess what I
was trying to say in this video is that
I have been thinking about the vlog and
I have been frustrated by it and I think
this is the best way that I can come to
terms with it is to use it for and its
inherent dumbness for good for a good
purpose so on this channel in the future
hopefully you're gonna see more stuff
like this as well as stuff which I enjoy
making like video essays and you know
particularly seems to be climate change
is gonna be a thing that I have a few
more video essays to make about that but
ultimately the thing that got me this
play button is vlogs with a point vlogs
which I think have an educational point
to them and have a little bit of brain
about them and whilst I don't want to
actually change the perception of vlogs
as being dumb because I think that
actually helps this cause I hope that I
can convince at least you guys in my
audience that you don't necessarily have
to think or be prepared to think to
learn something on YouTube thank you so
much to the central laser facility for
inviting me out to you it was a really
really fun time and I honestly can't
wait to get to work on the videos I
think there's gonna be two videos coming
out of that trip and also thank you to
the London small youtubers event I
didn't vlog too much cuz I was kind of
deep and thought about this video but it
was lovely to me a bunch of you that was
also just you know it's always great to
meet other creators and you know if you
are in London or in the southeast and
you are yourself a small creator then
look him up I'll leave a link down there
in the description and then last but not
least thank you all those of you who
subscribe to this channel you crazy cats
for you know getting me this play button
this is it's kind of I guess what I've
been dreaming about for a long time and
now it's here it's just it's a thing you
know it's a bit like when I talked about
my degree experiences and getting this
that are more valuable to me than the
actual physical thing but for what it's
worth thank yous of the hundred thousand
plus now people who subscribe to this
channel I hope I make it worth your
while
[Music]
you